belle tutti i ragazzi se una gara di
raimond essendovi insieme a fuochi j
ci vediamo che kidjo schietti e di
ragazzi dentro dal doppiatore di
doraemon è il massimo della vita 100.000
live solver questo ciao studiati mag i
veti che i ragazzi
l'apertura di blog da doraemon vale la
vita posso già vedere la [ __ ] forgia il
quale si gasa mi sta aspettando che
finisco il blog crew qua è un ragazzino
ho registrato una roba che vedrete
durante piuttosto la settimana prossima
come doppiatore di bernheim non è stato
bellissimo e l'altra una persona
supersimpatica quando io registro i blog
registro le varie scene durante la
settimana e poi faccio un video davanti
alla webcam dove introduco le varie cose
che sono successe non puntualmente io mi
trovo il sabato mattina a montare il
long e questo video dove spiego tutte le
scene lo devo fare prima di pubblicare
il video qui di sabato mattina quindi o
videro un fischi re mettere a posto le
luci le cose pettinare ma perché lo
shopper e stamattina non avevo un cazzo
voglia quindi ho detto facciamo queste
introduzioni di blog in pigiama fotte
cazzi quindi ragazzuoli passando anche
cosa è successo durante la settimana la
settimana scorsa eravamo in turco di
mail e quando amiamo in tour in giro per
l'italia in genere siamo in albergo
ovviamente è ovviamente se in albergo
playmates non è tranquillo vi lascio a
ciò che è successo in albergo l'ultima
volta che siamo andati in tour i ragazzi
vi spiego la situazione siamo saliti in
albergo ea me dovevamo arrivare dal
piano 0 al piano 11 quindi 11 piani di
ascensori e stefano ovviamente ha
schiacciato tutti i tasti dell'ascensore
qui ci siamo fatti tutti i piani prima
di arrivare all 11 lorenzo mi hanno
smagnetizzato con dio e sul core a
grazie ma cosa stavo spiegando lo devo
successo
lo zaino quindi praticamente si sono
aperti una riga ma basta questo
l'ascensore si avvertì la negazione
distanza ma che cazzo fragola il caso si
dimostri se ma vissute fonda si no
canzoni casa mia la stanza a chiave
l'ascensore sia perché in tutti i piani
e in tutti i piani ovviamente c'era la
luce così no sia aperto all'ottavo era
buio sembra un film dell'orrore
bruttissimo stiamo andando all ottavo
piano vedere che grasso c'è era horror
avete idea le squadre sono stefano ok
siamo io papà e simon weil piano 821 via
meno male che ci sempre cosa c'è stata
rivelata ma bravo giuseppe o meno male
che ci sei tu giuseppe seguente queste
speciali stato bruttissimo
nella pancia di sasha a disposizione non
opap a napoli ma di auto creatività non
si sa perché c'è il tappeto che sapeva
gruppo guarda ma una nobile chiudetelo a
fare cosa obiettivi c'è una spalla
meritano usato un'arma saprai sasha mi
chiamavano spendono torcia raga è la
cosa più macabra che abbia mai visto
cuocere il pane elettrico i giochi
insegnano di accende la luce ne sono
provate venire qua di notte non sacco di
volte due armi o due armi
marco insieme aprite dai bastardi lo
sapevo la star ha giocato i giochi ai
più che ora andiamo avanti ma che
segnava infatti non è non è un gioco
quindi lanciano le cose da ieri e prese
elettriche in queste fazioni piano
sinistra o destra ma se in scena ma
porca vacca
devo chiudere il piano per quello che mi
risulta uno da sasha bye bye bye lo fa
va fatto cambiato come di facciamo noi
intro bella era il successo c'è nessuno
ma se c'è qualcuno uscite come si fa
italiano cos'è tubi con 803 803 successo
devono famiglia intanto su sacco nero
anche in degrado cena si muoverà solo
808 perché quando la lotta piccola che
cazzo era siete dei deficienti ragazzi
humans affari
[Musica]
a tutto questo papa è successo perché ma
giuseppe dove ragazzi dove giuseppe dove
giuseppe ragazzi una ragazza ovviamente
dove giuseppe e come può più perché non
sapendo se sarete ragazzi nostro quello
di buono che senza poi avete chiamato i
nove anni nonno non sarebbe giusto cose
non sono state proprio le dita negli
occhi al coraggio di inserire in una
casa saranno anche qui perché sia bar
chiuso
no ma fermi o no ma non si fa così
[Applauso]
ci sono adesso bisogna molto in quanto
le gare del sono basta perché da dormire
base ai ragazzi questo è quello che
succede se se fate le cose con stefano
sasha salvatore giuseppe giuseppe no
perché giuseppe tranquillo gli altri
ispirano l'omicidio e l'altra cosa
particolare che è successo durante la
settimana che forse sarà anche la
copertina di questo video perché è
giusto fare chi gbyte per fare i big
mornay è successo che ho incontrato
francesco gabani che l'autore della
canzone occidentalis karma che è la
canzone che ho parodizzato connettersi
in italia che tanto mi ha fatto i
complimenti per come canto io
in uk cosa
[Musica]
il lieve grazie francesco sei stato
molto gentile però sono presenti e tra
l'altro aveva un sacco voglia di
presentarmi in pigiama con lui però ho
detto vabbè tanto so se ha visto che
sono un [ __ ] quindi non c'e neanche
bisogno che io lo faccia lo sa lo sa
comunque ragazzi domani ci sara io verrò
in pigiama ci sarà una data a milano che
sarà la data più importante del tour
secondo me perché milano è la data in
cui no che l'altro non sei importanti
fra milano siamo in casa dobbiamo
spaccare tutto aderire tutti i ragazzi
domani non deve esserci a madonna
chiarire anche questo come possiamo
concludere qua però però vi voglio dire
che durante la settimana usciranno delle
robe che non ho messo in questo perché
sono troppo particolari tenere i
prodotti per questa settimana cari a chi
c'ha a peggio merda comunque in tutto
questo volevo dirvi di auto adesso mi
sta piacendo un botto e che questo non
gli riesce alla propria la terza puntata
che sarà una bomba adesso mi cambio eva
da giocare un po outlast perché è quello
che faccio io sabato
beh ragazzi sono rivolte le sorprese di
kinder sorpresa ed entro cioè fuochi j
la mia vita è completa
[Musica]